machine learning is a method of data
analysis that automates analytical model
building
it is a branch of artificial
intelligence based on the idea that
systems can learn from data
identify patterns and make decisions
with minimal human intervention
because of new computing technologies
machine learning today
is not like machine learning of the past
it was born from pattern recognition
and the theory that computers can learn
without being programmed to perform
specific tasks
the iterative aspect of machine learning
is important because as models are
exposed to new data
they are able to independently adapt
they learn from previous computations to
produce reliable
repeatable decisions and results it's a
science that's not new but one that has
gained fresh momentum
while many machine learning algorithms
have been around for a long time
the ability to automatically apply
complex mathematical calculations to big
data
over and over faster and faster is a
recent development
here are a few widely publicized
examples of machine learning
applications you may be familiar with
for example a heavily hyped self-driving
google car
online recommendation offers such as
those from amazon and netflix
knowing what customers are saying about
you on twitter
and fraud detection one of the more
obvious
important uses in our world today
why is machine learning important
resurging interest in machine learning
is due to the same factors
that have made data mining and bayesian
analysis more popular than ever
things like growing volumes and
varieties of available data
computational processing that is cheaper
and more powerful
and affordable data storage all of these
things
mean it's possible to quickly and
automatically produce models that can
analyze bigger
more complex data and deliver faster
more accurate results
even on a very large scale and by
building precise models
an organization has a better chance of
identifying profitable opportunities
or avoiding unknown risks
to create good machine learning systems
you will need data preparation
capabilities
basic and advanced algorithms automation
and iterative processes
scalability and modeling
there are some differences in
nomenclature used in machine learning
versus traditional statistics
for example in machine learning a target
is called a label
in statistics a target is called a
dependent variable
a variable in statistics is called a
feature in machine learning
and a transformation in statistics is
called feature creation in machine
learning
two of the most widely adopted machine
learning methods are supervised learning
and unsupervised learning
but there are also other methods of
machine learning
here's an overview of the most popular
types
supervised learning algorithms are
trained using labeled examples
such as an input where the desired
output is known
for example a piece of equipment could
have data points labeled either failed
or runs the learning algorithm receives
a set of inputs along with the
corresponding correct outputs
and the algorithm learns by comparing
its actual output with correct outputs
to find errors
it then modifies the model accordingly
through methods like classification
regression prediction and gradient
boosting
supervised learning uses patterns to
predict the values of the label on
additional unlabeled data
supervised learning is commonly used in
applications where historical data
predicts likely future events
for example it can anticipate when
credit card transactions are likely to
be fraudulent or which insurance
customer is likely to file a claim
unsupervised learning is used against
data that has no historical labels
the system is not told the right answer
the algorithm must figure out what is
being shown
the goal is to explore the data and find
some structure within
unsupervised learning works well on
transactional data
for example it can identify segments of
customers with similar attributes who
can then be treated similarly in
marketing campaigns
or it can find the main attributes that
separate customer segments from each
other
popular techniques include
self-organizing maps
nearest neighbor mapping k-means
clustering and singular value
decomposition
these algorithms are also used to
segment text topics recommend items and
identify
data outliers reinforcement learning is
often used for robotics
gaming and navigation with reinforcement
learning
the algorithm discovers through trial
and error which actions
yield the greatest rewards this type of
learning has three primary components
the agent the learner or decision maker
the environment everything the agent
interacts with
and actions what the agent can do the
objective is for the agent to choose
actions that maximize the expected
reward over a given amount of time
the agent will reach the goal much
faster by following a good policy
so the goal in reinforcement learning is
to learn the best policy